ارحب مره اخرى بضيف السيد سونال تجاري
وكنا نتحدث عن خطوره السيطره على القبلات
الممتده في المحيطات والبحار كيبلات
الانترنت واعود لك سيد تجاري ارحب بك من
جديد ودعني اسالك عن
بنيه اللوغاريتمات اللي هي بفضل المعادلات
الحسابيه يمكن للمنصات عبر الانترنت اداء
وظائف تهم الشان العام في جزء من الثانيه
دون الاعتماد على اشراف سلطه حكوميه ما
الذي يعنيه هذا الا يمس هذا مبدا سياده
الدول كيف يمكن التعامل مع مثل هكذا موضوع
اعتقد انه تماما مثل ملف الغذاء الذي تنظر
الدول في كيفيه التحكم في برامجه بتخزين
كميه منه ينبغي عليها النظر الى الانترنت
وخطوط النطاق العريض بمثل هذه المقاربه
الاستراتيجيه
ينبغي لها النظر في خطط تمكنها من التاكد
من نفاذ مواطنيها الى هذه الخدمه الحيويه
في حال النزاعات ومهما كانت الظروف فمن
ناحيه الانفاق على هذا الامر فهو بكل
تاكيدا لا يتكلف الكثير ولكنه من الناحيه
الحيويه مهم جدا لبقاء الدول والمحافظه
على متطلبات العيش بين مواطنيها وايضا
بينها وبين باقي العالم
في عالم اليوم يمكن للفرد ان لا يتناول
وجبه غذاء مقابل عدم التنازلي عن لحظه على
الانترنت لذلك فقد بات هذا الامر مهما جدا
ويحظى بالاولويه المطلقه لدى الحكومات
التي يتعين عليها التحرك بقوه على هذا
الصعيد
لو ممكن ان تقدم لنا تصور عن كيف سيكون
الانترنت وميدان الاتصالات عموما بعد
سنوات لما يكتمل مشهد سيطره هذه الشركات
الكبرى على القطاع
اعتقد اننا بلغنا بالفعل نقطه لا عوده
التي من غير الممكن فيها تقريبا ان يتم
بناء خط من دون مشاركه واحده من شركات
عمالقه التكنولوجيا الاربعه عمليا وحتى
بحكم الامر الواقع اصبح ذلك في حكم الصعب
جدا واعتقد انه بات لزاما على الحكومات
الانخراط منذ الان وعدم اهدار الوقت في
هذا الملف للعب الدوري الذي تكون فيه
بمثابه المنطقه العازله التي تبدا الشركه
ببناء خطوطها ليس داخلها وانما بعد حدودها